hello and welcome to get commands my
name is chad anand and i am with this
simple own team today i'm gonna cover a
few essential git commands and walk you
through a demonstration for most of it i
begin by installing a git bash on the
git client and configuring it for its
first time usage once I'm done with
configuring the git client I'm gonna
spin up few repositories locally and
walk on these repositories using git
commands once I'm happy with my local
changes I'm gonna commit few of them and
then push these changes to a git server
of my choice for today's demonstration I
plan to use github comm which is a cloud
hosted free service and it provides free
account registrations for anyone
eventually I will cover few topics
regarding get branching and merging
because these two in my opinion are the
killer features of the get distributed
version control tool kit is one of the
most popular distributed version control
tools of recent times and like any other
distributed version control tool it
allows us to perform various version
control tasks without really needing a
network connection before I jump into my
demonstration let me spend some time
explaining to you then git client server
working model what does it take for a
couple of users to collaborate and start
working with get the bare minimal thing
that any user would need in order to
start working with git is something
called as git bash or the declined
this comes as an installer for all
popular operating systems like Windows
all flavors of Windows Linux Mac OS and
other operating systems so once you
install git bash you get a command line
utility using which you can fire up your
git commands and ensure that you can
bring up repositories you can work with
these repositories by adding files to it
committing changes to it and all those
git commands would work perfectly well
so you can bring up a small repository
and you can work with your repository
using this git bash but what does it
take for you to share this repository
with another user was also got get bash
install
on his system this is where you would
need something called as a git server so
for user one or one user to share his
repository with another user he would
need to collaborate using something
called as a get server so in the present
market there are a bunch of get servers
which are popularly available some of
them are free some of them come with a
cost because they are licensed a bunch
of these servers that I can think of are
github which is one of the most popular
kids servers there is around in the
market for a long time now it comes with
two variants one is the cloud hosted one
which is the github.com and then the
other one is an enterprise server which
comes as a black box that can be
installed into your data centers so
typically organizations who don't want
their source code to be put up on the
cloud but go for this github enterprise
servers who are in the buy this service
and these servers are hosted on the idea
centers other popular variant of the git
server is bitbucket this is from the
famous Atlas Ian products and it
integrates very well with all other
Atlas in products like JIRA in recent
times there's one other variant of the
git server called git lab which is
getting very very popular these days
because git lab not just provides a git
server it also provides something called
a serve runner
this is a part of the continuous
integration strategy where as soon as
you have a source code checking that is
going in you have this runner that kicks
up and builds your particular project so
all these are bundled together in a git
lab and get lab also provides you with
the community edition which is almost
free of cost having said that there are
a bunch of these tools available for my
demonstration what I'm going to do is I
already registered myself on the github
comm by providing my username and my
password and I'm going to use a free
account
so whatever repository is that I'm gonna
put up on this server is all public by
default so I will register myself by
using my username or my email ID and my
password so this set of authentication
is also referred to as HTTP
authentication so in order for me to
share my repository with say user - the
first thing that I got to do was
have an access to a git server where
both user 1 and user two are set up so
once I have that I can push my
repository onto this server and provide
right kind of access so that user two or
the other developer over wishes to
collaborate with me on this repository
can use his credentials as long as his
resisted properly on the git server he
can use his credentials and pull down
this repository and work with this
repository so this is the HTTP way of
authenticating and sharing repositories
another popular way of sharing
repositories or working with each other
is called less as a setch authentication
as many of you would know ssh means
nothing but creation of a private and a
public key a bunch of keys public and
private are created on the client
machine why do i create a piece i will
be asked for a passphrase i need to type
in a pass phrase and remember passphrase
and then i take this public key and kind
of post it on to my account within my
git server so that whenever i'm gonna
connect next time using my command
prompt or any of the tools it's going to
challenge me for my pass phrase as long
as I remember my pass phrase correctly I
can authenticate myself and get into the
server so both HTTP and SSH are popular
ways of communicating with thee it's
over having said this let me just get
started by installing the git bash on my
local system and then fire up some of
these git commands and build up some
repositories make some changes in my
repository commit these changes and
later use my github credential to
connect to my github server and push my
repositories out there let me now go
ahead and find my git bash for my
windows so that I can go ahead and
install it so I just type in get Klein
for windows open up a browser and type
in for this the first one that I find is
a GUI tool I don't need this GUI blind I
need this one so this is the git client
or the git bash that I was referring to
it's about 40 Meg's and let me just
download this pause this video for some
time so that the download happens and
come back to you once I have the
download the download seems to be
complete and I'm recording this video
the version that I
I have the latest version that is there
is two or 19.0 and this is a 64-bit
version for Windows so god that
downloaded let me go ahead and find it
and install this exe alright
I go ahead choosing all the default
options I want it to be installed in C
colon program files under the git folder
everything looks good for me I'm not
gonna make any changes here git bash for
Windows yes I don't want to use git from
Windows command prompt that sounds good
for me
OpenSSH that's fine
looks good looks good no I don't want
any of these new features
so what I'm doing is installing the gate
bash or the get trained so that I can
start using my bit commands the version
that I'm using is to dot 19.0 which as I
record this video this happens to be the
latest version
all right so looks good I don't want to
see the release notes I'll sing in
launch get bash
so what I get is this window so this is
the get command prompt so let me check
if everything is looking good say gate
to ocean it sounds good
say get help all right a lot of get help
commands everything looks good so I
ended up installing the gate bash I can
go ahead with all other commands
now that I have git bash installed on my
system let me open up a git bash prompt
and start using it but before I do
anything I just need to configure it for
the first time stating what would be the
user name and the email ID with which I
want the gate bash to be configured with
the command to do that is get config - -
global which means that this setting
that I'm gonna set would be a global
sitting user dot name and this the name
of the user who needs to be specified
within a double curl in my case I am
using a simpler account this is the
official account and this is the
particular user name of this account the
other setting is nothing but git config
- - global this is also a global setting
and this would be the email ID
the email 18
not contain a double coat so in my case
this is the email ID that I would be
setting up good to work with all right
let me check if the configurations were
set correctly or not
all right if you see this they user name
and the email ID has been picked up the
way I wanted it to be picked up looks
good so far all right so what do we do
next
by default whenever you open up the gate
prompt you're placed into your home
directory let me create a folder here
which would be a repository folder from
where I'm gonna create all my multiple
git repositories so I would create a
folder called let's say git underscore
demo all right
this already a folder called get demo so
let me just delete it in the first place
and let me create this kid to move again
all right let me navigate to this
particular folder
so this is the folder let me open up
that folder using a command prompt
the sis market demo so this would be a
folder said I would use this folder as a
base folder for creating all other
repositories as a part of this demo so
let me create my first repository a
repository is nothing but a folder so
let me create my first folder called
first repo and let me get into the
syllable
alright as of now this is just an empty
folder if at all I navigate to this
you'll see that this folder is empty
there's nothing much in this folder at
all
at this moment okay so let me create a
repository out of this how do I create a
repository of this is pretty simple I
just run and get in it command when I
say get in it it means it's gonna
initialize a repository as of now the
folder contain nothing on it was an
empty repository so it initialize an
empty repository in this particular
folder if at all I look at my content
you see that there's a hidden folder
this would be a hidden folder since I
have configured my Explorer to view all
the hidden food as I see it otherwise
you wouldn't see it so a folder by name
dot kit is created within this first
repo and this was created because we ran
the command git init if I get into this
folder I see a bunch of directories and
other configurations if you see there's
something called as a hooks territory a
couple of configuration files that are
here in this directory all these relate
to one or the other type of a client
hook that can be enabled and there's
info this objects this references a
bunch of stuff that is there so what is
this folder this is a magical git folder
and this is created whenever a
repositories initialized so by default
if at all you get into any git folder or
any git repository you would see this
dot git folder a word of caution do not
get into this folder and try to modify
anything because if you fiddle around
with this and corrupt this particular
folder your whole repository will go for
a toss so let me come out of this
let me show you another thing now if you
notice here when I was in the folder the
repository did not have anything after
this now when I say get in it there is
something called as a master that shows
up so typically what happens is whenever
a git repository is created for the
first time it creates a default branch
the name of the branch is called master
and that is why you would see master
within braces this doesn't mean anything
else other than we have a repository out
in this particular folder and by default
there is a branch called master and we
are currently on that branch if at all I
create multiple branches in this folder
and whenever I navigate to different
branches the branch name within this
brackets would change alright so far so
good so we created a folder we made it a
git repository by initializing that with
a git init and then I have not put
anything yet in the repository try to do
that let me create a few files within
this particular repository so I use a
touch command touch is a Linux command
it kind of creates this particular
folder ictal you're not comfortable with
the file creation by this way you can
always use a file explorer and create
some files in this so I create a file
called touch master or text and open up
in the notepad okay so this is my first
file that's what I'm going to write
inside this
this and it come out of this all right
now let me do a git status command so
what does this tell you there's no
commits said you're on the master branch
there is an untracked file and this
shows up in Fred it also gives you all
the commands that is supposed to be run
so if at all you want to add this file
you would say get AG and the name of the
file and then you're gonna commit it so
what happened is that when the
repository was initialized it was an
empty repository now that I get notices
that there is a new file in this
repository called master dot txt if at
all you want you want us to let get know
that you want to track this file we need
to add this to the repository so the
command to add that is called git and I
can specify either the name of the file
or I can give a wild character saying
git add dot now if I run the git status
command again
it says there's no committee yet added a
file and the file which was earlier in
red now shows up in clean and it says
it's a new file master dot txt all right
it also gives you something called git
remove command if at all you want to
unstaged or undo your changes so what
has happened is the file which was
earlier on track it's been added into
the get index or it is ready for staging
or it's in the staged state now I can go
ahead and commit this file if at all
that's what I want to do so let me do
that I'll do a git commit minus M and
they give a message that I want I would
say this is my first gate commit
all right I run the git status command
again and see it says on the branch
master nothing to commit it's all nice
and clean so typically what happened was
I created the empty directory made it
into a git folder by doing a get in it I
put a file into it I made some changes
to the file I added that file into the
repository and I committed to the
repository if it were her
I run the git log command it says this
was the commit ID or the commit number
or the commit hash tag and this is the
author if you notice this is the email
ID and the username that we set earlier
and this was done on this date and this
is the commit message that is there all
of it looks so good let me do one more
commit into this repository so I will
touch master one dot text I'll put in
another file I'll open up this
particular file
I write something into this
right I save this change let me also
open up the older file make some more
change into this alright so what I did I
modified the older file that existed I
also added a new file to my repository
now if I run the git status command
it says modified this file which is
showing in red and it says you have one
more file which was an untracked file
alright now let me add both these files
because these are the changes that I
want to incorporate I would say git add
dot I don't the get status command again
and it says now this is a modified find
this is a new file looks good to me let
me go ahead and commit this so get
commit with a message that says this is
my second commit alright if I do get log
now it shows boot the commits the first
commit is the one that shows up at the
bottom and the topmost one is the latest
commit that is there so far so good if
at all you notice I'm doing all these
git commands without really connected it
to any git server I don't need any
network connection for doing any of
these things I can keep on doing more
and more git commands and run git
commands the way I want to without
really having any connections to the kit
server now that I have my changes the
way I wanted and I've checked in all the
code changes into my local repository I
may want to share my repository with
somebody else and work in a
collaborative way so the way to do that
is as I mentioned earlier to host this
repository or to push this repository
onto a git server I already have a
github account wherein have registered
myself using my username and password so
I log into my github account using my
username and credentials and let me go
ahead and create a new repository
my repository is already there on the
local system so what I essentially need
is just a placeholder for my repository
so that I can link them together and
push the content from my local
repository to the server if you notice
the name of my repository is his first
repo so let me copy this I would create
a folder structure or a repository
structure on the server with the same
name so that when I pushed my repository
from my local box it would go ahead and
get created in the server so the
repository name should be the same as
what I created on my local box
description I would say this is my first
gate hub repository on the server this
is just an optional description that
will show up and if you notice I can't
have any private repositories so
whatever repositories that I'm gonna
create here would be a public repository
so I choose public and I don't want to
initialize this with a readme file or
anything of that because I already have
a repository with some content with some
code checked in all that I need is a
placeholder for my repository on the
server so with this option with just the
name and with an optional description
and the repository being public I go and
click on the create repository button
so if you notice it gives me a bunch of
commands that I would need to run in
order to create a repository and pushed
onto the server and also important point
it shows me two URLs
one is the HTTP URL and the other one is
the SSH URL as of now we do not have any
SSH keys that is setup so let me use
this HTTPS URL to connect my local
repository with the repository on the
server so I've done all these things I
already have the repository set up all
that I need is a placeholder for me to
connect my local repository with the
server URL so this would be the command
that I need to copy which essentially
links or adds an origin with the URL of
the git server I just copy this command
and run it here get remote add the name
of the remote is called origin and it
points to an HTTP URL which is nothing
but the placeholder that I've created on
the server alright so let me check if
it's added correctly
okay the URL looks good I'm all set I've
got two commits in my repository I'm
done with all the changes so let me try
to push my repository onto the server
the command for doing it for the first
time is get push - you this is for
linking the upstream
origin/master so gate push - you
upstream linking origin master link the
master a branch of my local repository
with the master branch on the server
repository and where is it going to push
it is going to push by default to an
origin and the origin points to this URL
all right let me try doing this
so it essentially opens up on URL asking
me the credentials with which I need to
log into my lead observer so let me just
copy and paste the username and the
password with which average is still
I will say Logan
okay success so I am able to create a
repository on the server and the content
seems to be pushed and it created a new
branch called master it has linked the
master branch from the local repository
with the master branch on this server so
let me go back to my server and refresh
this page
and see if all my commits have come in
master master one dot txt if at all I
see the Comets they seem to be two
comets this is my first commit this is
my second commit and if at all you
notice each of this commit comes with a
hash key or a hash ID which contains the
details of my commits in this commit the
files were added this was line that was
added if you look at the second commit
I added these lines I made this you know
one line chain that was there I also
added this new file which was not
existing these are the two commits that
existed and if you see the timestamp of
the commit this is the commit which was
committed for 15 minutes ago
so what does this mean is that the
commit is the timestamp when we actually
committed the code in the client the
pushing is just after we have committed
the change we have pushed it so there's
no time stamp of the push that happened
this completes the first part of the
tutorial
wherein I create a repository on the
client and then I pushed it to the
server after creating a repository
skeleton on the server now let me
demonstrate to you the SSH configuration
that is required for creating a pair of
SSH keys and ensuring that I connect to
the github server using the SSH
mechanism for doing that I need to first
create a pair of private and public key
the command to do that is is a search
keygen
- tea I will use the RSA mechanism for
creating my keys capital C and I need to
specify the email ID using which I'm
going to connect to all right I need to
create the keys for all right so
generating a private and public key pair
it says let me know what folder should I
create the keys in so by default the
keys are created in the user home
directory under a dot is assets folder
so this is pretty good for me so let me
go ahead and say that that's fine enter
a passphrase so let me enter some
passphrase keep in mind that I would
need to remember my pass phrase because
when I am going to authenticate myself
using SSH mechanism it will challenge me
for this particular passphrase I need to
enter the right pass phrase so that I
get authenticated so the key is
generated and by default it is created
in this particular folder so let me go
over to that particular folder
and this is the folder where the keys is
generated you would see a public key and
a private key that is created let me
open up the public key with a notepad
and then copy the contents of the whole
file
and now I would need to stick it in on
the server so that I can get myself
authenticated using SSH keys so I have
logged in to get up using my credentials
and go to my settings
and you will see an SSH and GPG keys let
me click on that as of now there are no
SSH key or GPG keys so I would click on
newest as his key and let me paste my
public key that I've copied and I would
say Paris's H key it prompts me for my
password just to make sure that
the right kind of authentication to be
adding a new key so this one looks good
that means the keys were added
successfully let me check if my SSH keys
are working well
so I do SSH - capital T I would say get
that did hub dot-com this is just to
double check if my SSH keys are
authenticated correctly are you sure you
want the connection yes you want to
continue yes all right now a check for
my passphrase let me enter my password I
hope I remember it correctly
alright triggered I have been
successfully authenticated so that means
now my CH keys are good and just by
using my passphrase I can connect to my
github server using SSH alright so for
the second use case what I would do is
create a repository on the server with
some content in it and then clone that
repository cloning is nothing but making
a copy of that repository linking the
origin so that I create an exact replica
of the repository which is there on the
server on my local Drive so let me first
create a repository on the server I will
create a new repository let me give a
name for my repository and let me kind
of initialize that with the readme file
I would call this my second repo give
some description this is my second repo
that is created to straight on the gets
over on the github server to precise
it's a public repository this time I'm
going to choose this option the reason
being that I don't want to create just a
skeleton as of now I want to create a
repository with some readme file in it a
random readme file with no content in it
but then I want a repository to be
created on the server alright I say
create a repository
so a random readme file with some
content in it gets created and I can see
there are two URLs to this repository as
to DPS and SSH so this time let me copy
the SSH URL so that I will use this URL
to clone this repository on the server
rather from the server to my local box
alright so let me navigate to my root
folder the folder that I created for
making all my repositories git
repositories if you see my first deposit
is already here so let me clone my
repository the second report that I
created on the server the command to do
that is get clone the URL of the
repository that I want to clone lips
looks like Heron copied the URL
correctly
copy that again copy this URL alright so
if you notice there is no HTTPS to it
I'm just cloning the URL that is SSH URL
of the repository
it asked for my pass phrase again
okay so I just had first deposit the
earlier now I have something called a
second drip oh this is an exact replica
of whatever was the repository content
that was created on the server so if I
get into the repository there's just a
simple readme file that is there let me
try to add a new file out here I would
say notepad second or text some text
file I'm gonna put in here yes
definitely you will not find that file
there
this is my second file that I will push
on to the server
I'm gonna put in some content out there
save this
it's status
it says this this is a new contract file
do you want to add this file on to the
repository do you want to track this
file yes I definitely want to track this
file
let me also commit my change to the file
with a message this is my first commit
for this second repo
forgiving some particular message and
this time around since I clone my
repository from a server the origin is
already set for me I don't really need
to add the origin in all that stuff
because what happened in the first case
was that I was creating a repository
from my local box and then pushing her
another server which is why I had to set
up the upstream branches and stuff like
that in this case I have cloned an
existing repository from the server so
when I clone I get the replica along
with all references to my repository so
I don't need to do anything more and
then push the content I was just say git
push to be in the safe aside I would say
origin and master
to ask me for the passphrase
okay he pushed the
servers let me see in the contents of
coming here okay wonderful I had only
one commit now I see my second comment
so what was added as a part of the
second commit it says a new file was
added all this line that never existed
got added this is the second file the
content exactly what I pushed onto the
server now this completes the tutorial
when I created repository on the server
cloned it made some changes to the
repository and pushed it to the server
using SSH a quick recap of all the git
commands that we ran till now git init
is used to initialize a repository so if
at all you're creating a local
repository you can get into any of the
folder which is not a good repository
and run this command whenever you run
this command a magical folders by name
dot kids gets created in the folder and
from that time onwards git will start
tracking any changes that happen to that
particular folder it also creates a new
repository and a branch by default the
branch that is created is called the
master branch git add dot is a wild-card
character for adding any number of new
files into your get repository if you
have a bunch of files one file to file
10 files of folder containing multiple
files in it all of them could be added
into the repository using this command
so once you add any number of files into
the repository you can keep on adding
more and more files into the repository
once you're done with that you want to
commit the changes that has happened in
the repository you use the git commit
command git commit - M with a meaningful
message this will commit all the work
items that you've done in terms of the
files that got changed the more files
that got added all this with one
particular message get status will give
you the status of all the files and
folders any file that got added any file
that got created any file that was
deleted all status of the files will be
obtained using the get status command
git log will show you all the commits
history with the latest history or the
latest commits showing up on top
git
and remote origin this command is used
whenever you want to link any local
repository to a server and this is when
you want to really push a repository
from the local to the server for the
first time git push - you origin and
master this is the command that you
would use whenever you want to push
contents from the local repository to
the server get clone and the URL of the
server this is the command that you will
run whenever you have an existing
repository on the server and you want to
make a fresh clone or a fresh copy of
that particular repository onto your
local box more than often many
developers or get users find themselves
in situations where they would want to
go back in history and modify or change
some of the files that they recently
committed or checked into the repository
now from a perspective of gate this is a
very very simple activity however my
perspective version control tool you
will have to be really cautious about
the chain that you're gonna do in case
the changes are pretty local none of the
developers or none of the other users
who are collaborating with you would be
affected by this change you're good to
go ahead and make this change
however if your repository has been
pushed to the server and you're trying
to modify something from history this
would have a very bad or adverse effect
on all the other users will be using it
you need to be really cautious while
running these commands in case your
repository contains our local if not
pushed your changes to your repository
and if at all you made some changes to
the repository maybe to fix a defect or
to include a new feature and you miss
few things you can go ahead and modify
this with some of these commands let's
say I have this simple repository called
undo undo repo and if at all I look at
the logs of these I have the committee's
trees which are like this
I have about five commits that is there
in my repository and in c1
added a file in c2 hour and the file in
c3 I've also added some file in c4 I
made some changes to M 1 and M 3 and in
C 5 have added another file called M for
now this is my commit history now let's
say I made these two commits but
possibly I want to Club them together
along with some other changes because
whatever changes I did did not really
fix things the way I expected you to fix
so there is a good command called it
reset this would allow me to go back in
history to go back to any of the
snapshot get rid of all this commit
history on the commit messages but
retain the changes that were made as a
part of these comments so if at all I
need to go back in history and go back
to this particular commit and however I
just want to get rid of these commits
that are there in terms of the commit
messages but I want the changes that
were there as a part of these commits to
still exist I would do command called
git reset - - soft now this would go
back or unwind my changes back to this
particular snapshot getting rid of all
the commit messages that were there as a
part of these two commits but a soft
would ensure that the file changes that
were done as a part of these two commits
would still exist a full remain so the
command for that is git reset - eff and
soft which is the snapshot that I want
to get back to if this is the commit
that I want to get back to I just copy
this and paste this alright it doesn't
give me any message but if at all I do a
good log pretty one-line what it says is
c1 c2 now the head which is nothing but
the current pointer which was earlier
pointing to c5 it's gone back to c3 now
what happened to the changes that were
there as a part of c4 and c5 if at all
you do a git status if you see the
changes that were a part of c4 was some
changes to m1 and m2 and see if I a new
final got m4 got added what I do I get
status you'd see those changes still
exist however from the git history or a
git commit history c3 is the topmost
commit that exists as of now c4 and c5
having gotten rid of but the changes
that were there still exist
alright now I can make some more
changes that I want if as a part of my
commit and possibly go ahead and come at
this whole thing as a new commit
altogether maybe I'll open up a notepad
and possibly create a new file called m6
dot text and say one new file that was
missed out I make this change I go to a
get status all these files are still
there I would say git add dot how said
git commit - M C for free writing
history
and I do a kick
love pretty there you go
so see one
to see three still existed and whatever
was a part of c4 and c5 the older ones
I've gotten rid of this along with those
old changes I also added a new file I
made some changes and it was able to
commit it now if I look at my gate
history it's all nice and clean however
do this activity only when you don't
push your git repository to the server
one other most powerful and useful
command while undoing or resetting the
history is something called as a revert
this is a safe way of undoing some
things remember what I talked about when
exactly you can do a reset it's only
when your changes are local and has not
been pushed to the repository take this
scenario we're in let's say I have a
good server
and I have the changes which are c1 c2
c3 and possibly c4 all right so this is
a bunch of comments that has happened
this was the oldest commit and this is
the newest commit and if at all
developer one is the one who's
responsible for pushing these contents
in the first place so he has got c1 to
c4 on his history I'm going to jump all
this c2 and c3 and carry to c4 and he's
pushed all this contents out here and
there are a bunch of people from the
server was pulled this repository and
all of them are the same level now
imagine a use case where developer one
then figures out that by mistake he put
in the c3 which was the wrong thing to
do and possibly you know he could have
done a better job of fixing this in a
different way so he wants to get rid of
the c3 or c4 or any one of these commits
if he's gonna do that and push it to the
server
first of all the git server would not
allow him to go back in history but
assuming that he forcibly pushed
something what would happen to all these
people who are looking to work ahead
from c4 all of them would be affected in
an adverse way so in short never go back
in history if at all you need to undo
something go ahead and put in a new
commit to undo something let's take this
example maybe if at all a developer one
wants to get rid of c3
a way to do that is by adding a new
commit which is ahead say let's say C
Phi and what does this come into this
come it possibly gets rid of this III
instead of going back in history it
actually is taking your get history I
had but as a part of this commit you're
undoing some part of the work that was
done as a part of c3 in short you're
removing a commit but to remove a commit
you're adding a new commit and this is
why you're doing it because there are a
bunch of other people who were your
who's this repository collaboratively
and work plan to get ahead in terms of
history they cannot afford to go back in
history and modify something in history
all right
the command to do this is called the git
revert command so let me take up this
repository which has got a bunch of
commits in it and if at all I do get log
14 one-line I have these bunch of
comments
and see one I've added a file in situ
our another file in c3 I've added one
more file and in c4 I made some changes
and this is the latest commit and this
is the oldest commit so if at all I see
the contents of the git folder
it contains m1 m2 m3 and m4 and let's
see looking at the previous use case
that I mentioned I may want to get rid
of this particular commit I want to get
rid of the c3 which is nothing but I've
added a file called m3 dot txt but I
added it by mistake I need a better way
of fixing it possibly I look at it later
on but for now I don't want this
particular commit and the changes that
were made as a part of that commit to
exist so the better way to do that is
using the get revert command so get
revert and the commit ID whatever I want
to revert so if I want to revert this I
copied this particular commit ID and
bear in mind that considering reset
revert works on one commit at a time so
I can do one commit revert at a time I
can Club a bunch of them together and do
one commit but otherwise the revert
always works on one commit at a time so
get revert face this essentially what
I'm trying to do I'm trying to undo this
particular commit while I'm undoing this
commit what does good do it seriously
adds a new commit and the part of this
new commit it undoes whatever changes
that were done as a part of this commit
so if I say git revert this all right I
forgot to mention a message which is why
this window showing up but that message
is good for me I say right and quit all
right and if I do a git log
all right if you see this Sivan still is
there in history and our history is
going ahead from CFI I see another
commit but what was there as a part of
this commit actually is getting rid of
this come at c3 so if at all I see my
files here
there's only M 1 M 2 and M 4 M 3 was
added as a part of c3 now I've gotten
rid of M 3 by getting rid of the revert
command for c3 so this is a better way
of undoing things now that we were
acquainted ourselves with few of those
basic commands let me get into a very
very interesting topic regarding gate
which is about branching the topic is
interesting because it deals with
branches in a completely different way
compared to any other version control
tool in most of the version control
tools whenever you create a new branch a
complete copy or a subset of the whole
repository is created which in my
opinion is very very cost inefficient
because it is a very very expensive
operation both in times of time and the
disk space
however in gate you just create a very
very lightweight mobile pointer whenever
you create a branch there is no folder
or no copy of the repository that is
created in short the branches are very
very inexpensive in grid so go ahead and
create any number of branches that you
need however once you create your
branches do all the work relating to
that branch in that specific branch and
once you completed your task go ahead
and merge your branches back into your
base branch and then delete the branch
let me go ahead and create a repository
with some branches in this and give you
a demonstration of that so let me go
back to my base directory which is gate
demo and then I am going to create a new
folder here I'll create a folder called
orb details alright this is my folder
here
I navigate into this folder and let me
create a repository here I initialize a
repository and dot git folder is created
without any files in it so let me create
a few files in it say notepad name dot
txt
organization name I create a named or
text within this
maybe I'll create one more file in this
notepad employees dot text simply long
has a were three key employees
I just put in some content in this save
this content alright so if at all I do
get status I just see two files in it so
let me go ahead and add these two files
and let me commit my changes okay
commit - a.m. or - em
first coming
cific do a gig log I see only one commit
and there are two files and you can see
those two files that is here all right
so at this stage let me go ahead and
create a new branch and the command for
creating new branches get branch name of
the branch so let me name my branch as
bangle branch BLR branch and this
created a branch but I don't see any
changes in the folder structure or in
the file that exist here
I've just created this branch so if at
all I do a git branch
these two branches and whatever star
means I am currently in this master
branch so let me go ahead and get into
the Miller branch at this moment the
number of files that exist in this
repository Singh has observed in no
change in any of the branches both
master and Baylor branch on to the same
snapshot so let me get into the other
branch and the command to do that is
gate check out BL our branch now
actually switched in to Bangalore branch
if you see the content of the files this
exactly two files the way it was earlier
because I created a branch from my base
branch which is a master branch and when
I created a branch there were two files
existing here if you see the content of
these files they would all be the same
all right so let me create a fine that
is specific to panel branch so I would
just say notepad maybe I want to put on
the address of this organization
specific to Bangalore in this address
dot text
so I say notepad address dot text also
simply learn Bangalore office located in
some atras I would say Bangalore that is
the content of this file and I am
creating all this new file in this blr
branch so I was saying it add dot and
also gate commit - M Bangalore branch
commit all right
if you see this now I have an address
not text which is there only in the
manual branch but I'm presently on now
let me switch back to my master branch
the command to do that is gate check out
master branch if you remember when they
folk doubt or when I created a new
branch from the master branch I didn't
have this address not text in it so let
me go back to get did check out master
branch and keep noticing this
particulars what happened to the others
dot text it kind of disappeared how did
that happen
so all because of this magical git
folder so what happened is now git knows
that when you are in the master branch
the file that was there in the Bengal
branch which was called Lee I just dot
text didn't exist so git is playing
around with the file system snapshot so
if I come back let's say I come back to
get check out bangle branch if you see
this the address dot txt file appears so
this particular file is only present in
the branch and gate is playing around
with the file system snapshot by moving
the pointers across and ensuring that
whenever I'm switching to bangle branch
I see this address dot text when I go
back to my master branch I don't say
this manual branch contents which is the
address dot next
alright now that I created this branch
maybe I may need to push this on to the
server so let me go ahead and create a
particular repository structure on the
server similar to whatever we did in a
previous exercise so the name of the
folder needs to be exactly this one so
let me copy this and let me create a
repository very quickly go here and say
new repository alright this is the name
of the repository did France demo this
what I'm gonna put it as a description I
would say public I don't want any readme
files in it because I already have a
repository I would just say create a
repository alright let me use the ASIS
actually this is this is HR and this is
good for me so let me copy this URL let
me add it here I'm linking my local
repository with the server and I would
let me come back to my master branch
let me first push my master branch so I
would say gate
push - you origin master it asks for my
passphrase alright I pushed my master
branch it looks good it's his new bunch
must just created so if I go back to my
server and they do a refresh if you see
it says only one branch and it says what
is the name of the branch master if you
see the contents that is employees door
text and name dot text now let's try to
push the other branch that is there the
command to do that is a little different
compared to the way we created it on the
trying because on the client we created
the branch with a git branch command now
this branch doesn't exist on the server
and I need to push this new branch on to
the server so the command would be
Gate push - new origin and the name of
the brand that I want to specifically
push all right now
it created a branch out here totally
fresh of this all right
it's his two branches if I can into this
mandrel branch I would see the address
dot text if at all I go back into master
branch I would not see this enter star
text wonderful now let me do one thing
let me try to get the changes from the
branch that I created packing to the
master branch that is what I would mean
by merging I would want the changes that
is there as a part of the Bengal branch
to come back into my master branch so if
I go to it check out my new branch I see
this attention attack this is there only
as a part of Bengal branch now assuming
that I am done with the changes from the
banner branch I want to get those
changes back into my master so let me
come back to my master branch and the
way to merge in the changes sees git
merge so what is that you want to merge
I want to merge the Banger branch
changes and where will it much if you
merge it into the current branch that
I'm on presently I'm in the master
branch so this command would merge the
changes from the Bengal branch into your
master branch so with this if we keep
looking here the content that was there
that was added as a part of bamboo
branch which is nothing but the address
dot text this file should appear as soon
as we do a much all right so it happened
quickly and
would see this I'll just text that is
here so if you see let's check the
contents in terms of the git log alright
so there was only one branch that we had
earlier which had only one commit right
now we read this band new branch commit
which was there as a part of the
Bangalore branch commit so with this
change let me push this change on to the
server as well gate push origin master
right those changes were pushed to the
server and now if at all I do only fresh
out here okay I mean two branches the
princess's master even if I meant master
Prince I should see this address not
text that is there even if I am in the
pen revenge the content is all shame
because we immerse these two branches
now that I merged this branch I don't
need this branch anymore so I would go
and delete this locally as well as push
it onto the server so that it gets
deleted from the server as well so
delete branch locally the command is git
branch - Dee and the name of the branch
only thing you need to ensure is that
you should not be currently on that
branch which are trying to delete so I
would say git branch and I'm presently
in the master branch so I can go ahead
and delete the other branch so gate
branch - Dee manual branch
alright this got rid of our bender bench
locally
if at all I don't get branch - we it
shows there's only one branch as of now
however this branch would still exist on
the server because server doesn't know
anything about the changes that we have
done we need to specifically push our
changes onto the server okay - brands
are still here so let me go it and push
this changes so that the branch gets
deleted from the server as well the
command to do that is get push origin -
- delete and the name of the branch
all right so this went head and deleted
the branch from the server let's check
that okay if you see now there's only
one branch these are the basic steps
that you would need to know before you
work with any of the branches within kit
and as I said before the branches are
very very inexpensive indeed go ahead
and create any number of branches that
you want but just ensure that once you
create your branch finish up your task
and once you finish off your task go
ahead and read the branch and before you
delete the branch please ensure that you
merge in the branches so that you get in
or take in the work that was done as a
part of that particular branch to
summarize the get branching commands are
as follows to create a new branch you
issue a command get branch in the name
of the branch and this would
automatically spin off or create a new
branch from the existing branch from
where you issued this command if you are
on the master branch and if you execute
this command and get to branch a new
underscore branch it creates a new
underscore branch from the master branch
once you create a new branch in order to
get into this branch you would type in
git checkout the name of the branch this
would automatically switch the file
system snapshot between different
branches now the branches that are
created are by default created on the
local repository in case you want to
push any specific branch onto the server
you would have to issue a command gate
push - u origin and the name of the
branch so this will ensure that the
contents of the new branch are pushed on
to this server at any time if you want
to list out all existing branches on
your local repositories the command
would be gate branch
- AV assuming that you did all your work
in a new branch and you're happy with
the changes you would want to bring back
those changes into the master branch the
command to merge the contents of any new
branch into a master branch would be git
merge and the name of the branch and
this would automatically merge the
branch contains that you specified into
the branch on which you currently reside
if at all you're on the master branch
and feel sure command key
new underscore branch this would most
the contents of the new branch onto the
master branch so once you merge the
contents of any branch you would
possibly want to go ahead and delete
this branch so the command to delete
this branch locally is gate branch -
capital D in the name of the branch this
again would delete the branch locally in
order to make this change on the server
which is in order to remove this branch
from the server the command to do that
is get push origin - - dili and the name
of the branch
this would also delete the branch that
you created on the server thank you for
stopping by and watching this video and
I hope it was useful for you in learning
some essential git commands for more
such learnings please do visit us at
www.simpleandsensational.com